oh yes that's the uh craft using an
inertial mass reduction device right
okay so let's go through this these
microwave emitters what are they doing
what they use for is to generate high
frequency vibration of the plasma
remember there's like a xenon plasma and
that affects the outer
outer wall so it ro it it actually it
starts resonating it at very high
frequencies remember that outer wall is
electrically charged
and
it would have to be because
though the way the pius effect is
formulated
so um yeah go ahead forgive me if i
retread the same ground repeatedly it's
just how i'm understanding it i want to
make sure that i'm not misunderstanding
anything
okay so
we have this craft here
and
there is plasma where
sort of the plasma is
see where these waves are this is like a
it's like a fluorescent how there's a
fluorescent tube and it's hollow and
that's filled with a plasma or will make
it into a plasma so it's that there's
some plasma inside the walls
of right craft
right okay so there's some plasma and
then the microwave emitters are there in
order to accelerate their vibrational
frequency
yes
you you need that in order to get these
high frequencies of vibration
now exactly exactly how you'd make sure
that the plasma does not contact the
walls that's i cannot talk on this
podcast
okay and over here it says it's
dielectric liner so can you explain what
that is a dielectric liner
it would make sure that the electrical
charge is it's basically a boundary for
the electrical charge the electrical
charge cannot pass that it's like an
insulator that's what the dielectric
boundary so yeah and these microwave
emitters once they're turned on after
some time i don't know how long then it
will
induce the swinger effect
it will induce the frequencies that you
need to achieve the uh
the schwinger effect with
remember the whole idea the schwinger
effect is to
break down the quantum vacuum
which would mean to create
discontinuities in your space-time
so-called continuum
and once you achieve these so-called
voids within the vacuum then the craft
can be sucked into that area of
i believe uh dr david frohning or i'm
not sure whether yes dr frohning uh
spoke of it as a conditioned vacuum if
you refer to his work
david throning
i i think he goes by his middle name
somehow but his last name is froning
and he speaks of it as a conditioned
vacuum
whereby you can facilitate the movement
of
these
inertially reduced craft
i do believe his last name is froning i
think it's spelled f-r-o-n-i-n-g
throning another effect that you should
go over is the pregogan effect if i'm
pronouncing that correctly oh the
prigozine effect yes the pr ilya
prigojin i believe 1977 nobel prize
winner in non-equilibrium thermodynamics
the idea that if you have a non-linear
medium
which
could be a plasma again
if you inject
electromagnetic energy into it and then
you ex you somehow injected a source to
drive the plasma far from equilibrium
then
it is possible that these plasmas will
self-organize
thereby
giving rise to
what's called the prigogene effect
i'm not quite sure if anybody refers to
it as the pregoshin effect but he talks
of it in his nobel prize lecture
uh i think it's called time structure
and fluctuations
it was given
at stockholm in in
1977 upon receipt of his nobel prize
in non-equilibrium thermodynamics you
can actually see
he talks about
this idea
in the form of i believe he uh talks
about bernard cells bernard cells it's a
flu dynamic phenomena that occurs when
you have a certain layer of oil over
heated plate
and how eventually these
chaotic seemingly chaotic
cells eventually self-organize in these
these beautiful almost i think hexagonal
shapes
and hence the prigosean effect and it
can again it can be applied to any
non-linear medium i i choose a plasma
because it it is a an incredible struct
it's an incredible state think of it
it's the fourth state of matter
and i believe it's quite possibly the
bridge
to
let's call it quintessence for lack of a
better term yeah
what's meant by non-linear medium
a non-linear medium would be a medium in
which uh your energy
is quite possible would resonate will be
amplified
if added
it will no longer be
incrementally
amplified it'll be non-linear you see so
the effect would be parabolic for
example again the idea of instead of
omega omega square like you find in the
pius effect so
yeah
that's what i mean by an alien medium
okay so the non-linear medium is the
plasma and that's inside the resonant
cavity of this craft and that is
resonating because of the microwaves
yes sir
yes okay because you and as you add as
you as you uh
accelerate in frequency of these
um
exactly how how these frequencies uh are
accelerated i cannot speak on the
podcast but it it is feasible to get
this omega square effect rather than
your regular linear omega because again
we're trying to counterbalance this q
squared term this charge squared term
because you know
again it's hard to get that one coulomb
of charges you have assume yourself as
have remarked so but it is much
much better to get these high
frequencies
using either piezoelectrics or plasmas
under certain
structure